.
- - ... d'appartenir à un grand
enensemble qui est mû
papar les mêmes objectifs.
- - Le président du conseil
d'd'administration de Hockey
CaCanada, Michael Brind'Amour,
ququitte son poste. Selon lui,
ilil est inutile d'attendre avat
d'd'entamer une nouvelle ère.
IlIl écrit :
L Le président sortant, qui est
auaussi avocat, ne parle toutefs
papas de la responsabilité
dudu conseil d'administration
dadans le scandale. Il ne présee
auaucune excuse, ce qui dérange
lele co-fondateur de l'organisme
B2B2Dix.
DODOMINICK GAUTHIER cofondateurt
didirecteur des opération, B2Dix
- - Oui, ultimement, c'est le C.
ququi est responsable de tout ce
ququi se passe dans l'organisatn
àà ce niveau-là, mais il y a
dedes mécanismeses qui ont été s
enen place par des gens qui sont
papayés par l'organisation.
JeJe veux savoir c'est qui
etet je suis certain que
leles Canadiens veulent savoir
c'c'est qui. Et eux doivent être
imimputables de leurs gestes.
- - Peut-être que ce sont
dedes vedettes...
- - Le député Sébastien Lemire,
ququi a pu questionner
leles dirigeants de Hockey Canaa
enen comité, juge ce départ
ininsuffisant.
SESÉBASTIEN LEMIRE,
dédéputé du Bloc québécois
- - Est-ce qu'on peut tirer
lele "plaster" une bonne fois
popour toutes et pouvoir faire
lele ménage qui est attendu
papar l'ensemble de la populati?
LLà, ce que ça prend maintenant,
c'c'est des gens qui sont
dadans la pédagogie, qui sont ds
l'l'éducation, notamment au nivu
dede la santé et de la sécurité
sesexuelle. Ça va prendre des gs
ququi ont une connaissance très
didiversifiée du monde du hocke.
CÇa prend plus de femmes aussi
auau conseil d'administration.
- - La ministre des Sports,
PaPascale St-Onge,
a a répété qu'elle demandait
unun changement de culture
prprofond à Hockey Canada.
PAPASCALE ST-ONGE,
miministre des Sports
- - Avec cette démission,
jeje pense qu'on commence à voir
dedes fissures dans la forterese
etet c'est comme ça que la lumie
pepeut rentrer.
- - Le conseil d'administration
dede Hockey Canada se réunira
auau cours des prochains jours
popour nommer son nouveau
prprésident intérimaire.
PePendant ce temps, mardi,
lele Championnat mondial de hocy
jujunior débutera à Edmonton
dadans un climat de crise
popour la fédération et pour
soson président, Scott Smith, q,
lului, tient à rester en poste.
I Ici Antoine Deshaies,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa